The truth is we are going into the next
election. Reform will be strong
favorites and really whether reform win
or not will be decided by whether these
different groups of people these
different groups of voters are able to
do aggressive and relentless pursuit of
of unity and common ground. It's as
simple as that. Basically um we have
especially in this country a political
system which aggressively punishes
division aggressively aggressively
punishes division. What will probably
happen in the next election is that
reform will win an overall majority and
that will be simply because the the
people and the the politicians in this
country who do not support reform are
divided. So whether reform win or not is
basically a question of will the center
and will the left be able to be
aggressive and relentless in their
pursuit of common ground. And um I would
love for them to unite on the issues
which they have in common which I would
like to believe are fixing the economy,
dealing with inequality, dealing with an
unfair taxation system. If they are able
to be sensible, get their heads
together, focus on the message that will
win, which is inequality, distribution,
the economy, focus aggressively on their
common ground, try to avoid bickering
and raising the salience of their
differences, try to avoid raising the
salience of their opponents, then they
could win. If they're divided, they will
lose.